el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
acciones ejecutivas comprada crisis
climática
por eso hoy estoy haciendo una mayor
inversión de la historia 2.300 millones
de dólares para ayudar a las comunidades
de todo el país a construir
infraestructuras diseñadas para soportar
toda la gama de desastres que hemos
visto hasta hoy calor extremo sequía
inundaciones huracanes tornados
extranjeros sin embargo el mandatario
estadounidense no quiso declarar un
estado de emergencia climática que
permitiría promover una amplia gama de
proyectos de energía limpia
los activistas climáticos criticaron las
medidas que según ellos se centran más
en reaccionar a la crisis que en evitar
un mayor calentamiento global
es muy importante que abordemos ambos
aspectos la adaptación y la mitigación y
estoy a favor de cualquier política que
nos ayude a conseguirlo porque como he
dicho el próximo de carbono permanece
durante mucho tiempo
europa y eeuu viven olas de calor desde
hace semanas alrededor de 100 millones
de estadounidenses
actualmente viven en zonas que están
bajo alerta de calor el país también
está sufriendo de vastos incendios como
en california o texas pero los poderes
judiciales y legislativos no facilitan
el trabajo a byd en el congreso no
adoptó una ley con medidas cruciales
sobre el clima y la energía limpia y la
corte suprema- de mayoría conservadora
limitó el poder del presidente en la
lucha contra la crisis climática
recientemente al fallar a favor de
estados con gobernadores republicanos y
decidir que la agencia de protección
ambiental de los estados unidos no tiene
autoridad para ordenar reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero